the redesign m2 macbook air is going to
be amazing but with that said is it
worth waiting for it or should you just
buy the current m1 macbook air this is
the machine that is the closest to a
perfect laptop ever made and i'll answer
it up front no i don't think you should
wait for multiple reasons and today
we'll get into everything that we know
about this new macbook that's going to
be coming out and we do know quite a lot
from leaked schematics certain specs
ports performance that was released from
tsmc for the upcoming fab and these new
chips and i'll give you guys all of the
info to help you make the correct choice
let's start out with the design the m1
macbook air has the iconic wedge shape
that has been so popular for such a long
time now this machine actually isn't
that thin especially on this thicker
portion it's actually thicker than the
13 inch macbook pro but then because it
goes nice and thin and wedges to this
tiny edge here it just makes it seem
like such a thin machine especially when
you put it side by side with the new 14
and 16 inch macbook pros now the new m2
macbook air or macbook
that one is going to be dishing this
design and to be honest i'm quite sad
about it we have leak schematics cad
files we have lots of renders and it's
going to go to a square flat slab design
just like apple's new iphones the ipads
and pretty much everything that apple is
putting out the apple wash that's gonna
be coming out so this macbook is
definitely gonna take that shape and if
we look at the renders that we have
right now it is extremely thin the usb
type c port is basically the full width
or a thickness of the side compared to
the current macbook air where we have
quite a bit of extra aluminum on the top
and bottom but not only that it's
actually a lot thicker because it's
hidden with this little curve so that
macbook is going to be much much thinner
we also know that the screen size is
going to be the same it will not be
moving up to a 14 inch size but instead
the bezels are going to shrink and that
means that the actual footprint of the
new macbook is going to shrink so
overall it will be a smaller machine and
it will likely be lighter as well so
that will be another benefit now even
though i'm going to miss this wedge
shape one huge benefit is it increases
the internal uh area available for
batteries and other components so just
like with the new 14 and 16 inch macbook
pros because of the slab design without
any tapers they were able to increase
the battery size and give it better
speakers as well so the battery it could
stay exactly the same or they could
still make the battery a little bit
smaller thanks to improved efficiency
and performance which we'll talk about
in just a bit but i also expect the
speakers to be quite a bit better we do
expect it to get magsafe and i think
that is a huge deal not only because you
can you know prevent falls because it
automatically disconnects and have a
little led to tell you if it's charging
but also because that will remove one of
the ports being used for charging so
essentially instead of having just two
thunderbolt ports on this macbook air
the new one will have two extras on top
of charging so you kind of gain an extra
port which is really nice now personally
with the current macbook air there are
times where i am charging and then at
the same time
i want to plug in a few things and i
just can't i have to wait then unplug it
so it's not very often that happens but
that is definitely a benefit finishing
off the design we have to talk about the
biggest change and that is going to be
colors this is pretty much confirmed
that we are going to be ditching the
black bezels on the macbook air and
going to white bezels apple did that
with the imac they're going to be doing
that with the 27-inch imac the non-imac
pro model and of course the macbook air
is the most consumer friendly product it
is also going back to the white bezel
design that they had a few a few
different generations back in the day
and then with that we also are going to
get a white keyboard and that is really
going to differentiate the new macbook
air or the macbook compared to the
macbook pros where they're even added
like a dark anodized aluminum underneath
the keyboard so they're adding even more
contrast to those machines now we have
to talk about that screen some renderers
have notches in them some do not i
personally am not bugged by the notch
too much at least with the black macbook
pros because they can be hidden easily
but with this new macbook that's going
to be coming out i hope that they do not
include that notch that realistically
that brings us to webcams the reason
that we have the notch with the 14 inch
is because they put in an amazing 1080p
webcam that looks much much better than
before and they needed that extra space
and then maybe in the future also having
face id
but with these macbooks um if they do
not add the notch that means we're going
to get a weaker webcam maybe still a
720p or just a 1080p one that is not as
good but i think that is totally fine i
like the nice clean look without the
notch now as far as the screens
themselves we have a 400 nit brightness
high accuracy
screen lcd panel with the macbook air it
is good but it is nowhere near the 1600
peak knit brightness of the mini led xdr
display and that is what we are going to
be getting with the new macbook air now
that alone might make it worth it for
you to wait for the new macbooks that
screen is gorgeous the contrast is
fantastic watching movies on is great
and then if you work with hdr which is
not only for video now but hdr photos
you do definitely want to have a screen
like that and that is also going to be
raising the price which we will also
talk about after we're done with the
performance now as far as the pro motion
120 hertz that is not going to be coming
to this machine at least that's what
most people are saying they're gonna
leave that for the macbook pros just
like the iphone pro models get whereas
the regular iphone 13 or the mini they
stick with 60hz even though they both
have oled displays and now on to
performance a lot of people are waiting
for these machines because they want the
m2 chip the m1 chip even though it is
still amazing in terms of performance
more than powerful enough for almost
everybody and smoking the older intel
max well that is kind of old news people
want something new and better and the
new macbooks are going to get the m2
chip tsmc already gave us the
improvements of performance and
efficiency and so based off of that we
have some very clear numbers in terms of
performance and there are actually a
couple different options in terms of
depending on how apple does this we had
a couple scenarios we talked about
before and boats and areas have
excellent performance so as far as the
cpu we're going to get at least 1900
single core score which is going to be
amazing even beating out the current
12th generation intel alder lake which
has super fast performance but of course
needs a lot of
power now that is if apple runs the m2
chip based off of the a15 but in my
opinion with what apple is doing and
when they're gonna be releasing this
machine there's also very possible that
the m2 chip is gonna be based off of the
a16 processor in this case our single
core score will be over 2000 about 2057
and that is just jaw dropping
performance and as far as multi-core
that will be 9322
now as far as the chip layout we're
still expecting the same for performance
course and for efficiency cores it makes
a lot of sense in this kind of machine
so that will be the same but in terms of
graphics we are going to jump up from
the a core configuration that's been
down to seven cores up to a 10 graphics
core configuration that will be been
down to nine for the entry level model
and as far as performance if it's based
off the a15 that still gives us a metal
score of over 28 000 almost 29 and that
is including thermal throttling because
this machine is fanless but if we're
basing off of the a16 we are nearing 32
000 in terms of metal score now that is
getting us close to the base 14-inch
macbook pro not all the way there and of
course this thing also has a fan but
that is still insane performance now i
think that for most people that are
buying a machine like this they are not
just trying to maximize the performance
because it's already really good but on
the flip side we have efficiency and
tsmc already told us that it's going to
bring up to 22 percent better efficiency
and that means that the already
excellent battery life of the m1 macbook
air can be up to 22 percent better and
have better performance or they can make
the battery smaller for example the
12-inch macbook had just over a 40 watt
hour battery and it will still have the
same excellent battery life now i
personally am leaning towards that
smaller battery because we have info on
the charger in the box being a 30 watt
charger so that's nothing like the
charges that come with the new 14 and 16
inch macbook pros and in order for them
to still charge the macbook up fast
enough and we see the apples focusing on
charging 50 in 30 minutes
then it will need to have a smaller
battery to charge fast enough so that is
my opinion now as far as release dates i
personally think that we might not even
get
an m2 macbook air or macbook this year
you guys think about it just honestly
would apple be launching pro machines
still based on the m1 pro chips the m1
max putting out the mac pro which is
still going to be based off of those
ships and at the same exact time saying
hey we also have an m2 chip
i don't know to me it doesn't seem
likely we're still waiting for the imax
the mac mini imac pro that mac pro a lot
of machines i think it makes more sense
to give it a little bit more time and
wait till spring of 2023 to release this
redesigned machine because they already
have so many different things coming out
and then if they push things back which
as you guys have seen everything is
getting delayed even the ipad was
delayed by six months now we have ola
delayed imac pro delayed um there is
just a lot of pushbacks because of part
shortages so i would not expect it
anytime soon at least before fall or
maybe even spring and then with that we
also have the possibility of there not
being an m2 macbook air now we know this
machine is coming but the question is
will they call it the macbook air
they had the 12-inch render macbook
before they had the macbook for
everybody which was just called macbook
as well and i think if they're doing
such a big redesign new colors new
design they could just call it the
macbook and with that we're going to
talk about price points because if this
thing is coming with mini led display
the redesign magsafe i think they are
going to be raising prices and this
machine will not be replaced so the
macbook air will say the same entry
level for 999
and this new macbook will come out in my
opinion for 300 bucks we saw the apple
raise the prices on the macbooks apple
raised the prices on the 14-inch macbook
pros the 15-inch macbook pros the ipad
got a price increase with the mini led
so when we have such a new machine
that's redesigned after a while with all
these improvements i think it's going to
fit in right there at the 12.99 price
point and that is probably the biggest
reason why i think you should not wait
it's going to be a better machine but
this works for almost everybody and you
can buy it as low as 850 dollars we have
links down in the description and once
this new one comes out it still will be
priced the same meaning that you are
gonna have to wait for a long time and
spend more money you gotta ask yourself
the question
do you need to wait that long or can you
wait that long or would you rather buy
one of these enjoy it for nine months to
a year maybe a little bit longer and
then be able to resell it because the
resale value on these machines are
incredible and then if that machine
comes out and has all the things you
need you could upgrade at that point i
know a lot of people don't like waiting
but i think that makes a lot more sense
than just always thinking about well
what's the next big thing maybe i should
wait for that it's a con like a constant
rat race waiting for that to come out so
there you guys go we have the battery
life the design the performance all that
info is already in front of our eyes and
hopefully that helps you make the
correct decision should you buy one of
these amazing machines that's basically
the best laptop the most perfect laptop
that has ever been made or should you
keep on waiting let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below click that circle above to
subscribe to help us reach 1 million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been max
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]